good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Thursday hope
everyone's having a great day
thus far thus far great day
great thus day far right I'm so glad we
got that kind of like cleared up yeah
every permutation though I know you're
not really having a great day thus far
I'm running late I'm so sorry literally
I like did a panel this morning no big
deal yeah just like kind of like a huge
convention you know talking about the
business of podcasting business of
social media what was the convention ad
week colon social media week
oh cool yeah
cool yeah you know and there was tons of
toasters in attendance my age I see the
agencies agency toasters like they're
alive and well yeah no we have every
agency Community I believe that yeah and
it was great and it went so well and
literally took me almost two hours to
get home you know when you're like a
[__] road raging like I was gonna put
my hands around someone's neck and choke
them out and it was gonna be the [__]
crossing guard in Queens like what's
what are you doing what what are you
doing
like if I seem a little on edge today
that's [__] why oh my God I was like
no you need to get it out of your system
I was crawling out of my [__]
skin in the back of this [__]
car
you're gonna have to get it out of your
system now we honestly continue to like
talk about it until I don't want to talk
about it like it's seriously trauma
I don't want to talk about it
but I'm just saying if I seem a little
on edge today it's because I literally
almost choked a person
okay and that person's not gonna be me
no no no it would have been the crossing
guard in Queens great but you're not
feeling chokey now you don't want to
send someone to the jokey I don't want
to send someone to the show okay
um I don't know we'll say because you
like it
because I like it well you look great so
that's a good happenstance thank you in
the event I was really like excited to
come on here and like you know be
delightful but you know life gets in the
way when you live in New York City yeah
so we're recording late today the
episode will be uploading sorry guys but
we have so much to do today we are all
caught up Vanderpump Rules we watched it
all I actually am all caught up on Real
Housewives of New Jersey
cool did you see that Bo diddle it's
like yeah center of the drama I saw that
in page six because there's a lot of
talk about private investigators and
Louis like made an offhand remark in the
finale he's like I know things about all
of you guys Bo Dietl
just basically implying that he
hires investigator and then on watch
wrappings live he cleared it up he was
like I was just saying stuff and then
bodito said he did not work with Louie
and investigate Housewives right
so why the [__] did you bring it up like
it was so weird Louie's so [__]
talking like crazy so he's certifiable
and honestly before the finale party
which was like this crazy explosive
party he was like me like like right now
with like he was [__] activated about
some [__] like his face was so [__]
red he was like ready to choke someone
and the party hadn't even started how
was the season I'm not gonna lie I did
Skip with some of the early episodes
like it was it was boring but I I
apparently like Melissa and Teresa are
irreparable like and I wanted to know
what happened and I've seen so much
chatter online like team tree and I'm
like okay I've been to Melissa this
whole time but like let's see what's up
I'm still team Melissa of course you are
no it's people are insane no but you
typically don't agree with we typically
don't agree with the masses on
housewives but then I did a poll on my
Instagram and it was I was just
genuinely curious I'm like are people
team tree now and it was 75 Melissa so I
just think maybe like that's your fans
yeah that's true that's true yeah like I
attract you know logical energy yeah but
we as discussed like the Bravo fan is
all over the place can be wrong they do
buy tickets to Tom Sandoval's in the
most extras right speaking of
um Real Housewives I wanted to tell you
about this event I went to last night
for Lemmy the uh
gummy vitamin company that Kourtney
Kardashian started with Simon they
hosted like an event to celebrate the
fact that they're being sold in Ulta and
I got seated next to uba I saw who is
one of the new Real Housewives of New
York and you know I don't want to be a
freak like obviously like I knew who she
was she was like uber I'm like oh nice
to meet you I'm Claudia um and then we
like started chit chatting we like
talked the whole time and then by the
end I could be like yeah [__] I know
like I know everything
um she like actually made me want to
watch the show she's a delight like
she's so funny she's an amazing story I
couldn't believe when she told me she's
40. I literally thought she was 18. like
she's stunning you would have thought
she's like at the height of her modeling
career
I mean just just a real delight and she
was so we had like a deep convo you know
yeah she is very religious but she was
saying she eats Halal and I was telling
her how he kosher and she's like I eat a
kosher restaurant pretty much
exclusively because kosher food is
considered Halal and she was like have
you been to pastrami queen I'm like have
I've been typically she's like I got a
sandwich here every day like she was
just so cool and she actually really
made me want to watch a show and she was
like telling me she was like getting me
hyped about it she's like it's really
good okay and she really is like so
fabulous that I'm like well maybe the
group is fabulous like she was oozing
just like fabulosity and beauty and
glamor well last night during Vanderpump
Rules there was a commercial for new
Housewives and like you said it was just
like them smiling there was no footage
but it was giving like season one Real
Housewives of New York just like here's
the cast and then literally right after
I saw that I saw Uber on your Instagram
story and that's how I knew who she was
and we shared a cab home like we're like
best friends like she was like let's go
do dinner and I didn't know if like she
meant it but like I'm gonna be following
up for like dinner plans at pastrami
literally literally it was just it was
fabulous like I was just not expecting
to like make a new best friend I don't
so happy for you we've really connected
on a deep level like my half of the
table we got deep we were talking about
like religion there was another girl
there who was Jewish and Israeli so we
were just like getting deep that's so
great yeah we were just kind of like
holding court at the end of the table
you know that's so great and how was the
rest of the event it was fabulous
Satchel the food I heard that snatcher
was Satchel was there Satchel was in
attendance Satchel had to go uh to
another thing so she like left kind of
early which kind of opened it kind of
opened me up to like open my heart up to
Uber like yeah you know when you get to
go it's such a privilege to get to go to
these events like with a built-in plus
one because Margo's obviously like an
influencer so you know people really
show up to these things they're to see
the dinner it's not a free-for-all
people show up by themselves and it
could be hard but you'd have to put
yourself out there but having a built-in
satch is amazing but it is a crutch
because you could be clicky we were you
know we're the worst and once she left I
felt like you know I got a
I gotta do my thing and I opened my
heart up to receive love from Uber
beautiful yeah oh and Uber has known
Taylor strecker forever so I felt like
that was like a good um
like starting conversation like hey like
I know Taylor and she was telling me how
she knew Taylor when she was married I
didn't know Taylor when she was married
she was like it was she was just
explaining to me she was like two
different tailors like it was I actually
like I was like jealous that she knew
Taylor Striker like I don't know that
part of Taylor yeah she was like it was
so crazy
crazy I know that's like when we watch
trolled Vlogs exactly JTV check it out
um so it was really a fabulous night out
with the girlies and then I ran home I
was like I'm gonna leave early and just
run but I was having such a nice time
and the food was so good I was like why
should I run and then I did end up
running home but I stayed like a good
amount of time and we watched underpron
pearls and Ben was like oh I want to go
to sleep I'm like shut up and he was uh
no all day Zach was like do you know
what tonight is I was like yeah we were
so excited to watch YouTube TV like I
crapped out last night at the second
half of Watch What Happens Live I
Googled I like looked on Twitter and I
think it was because of the NBA game
that was happening Andy said it was
because of REI I know
um and then I gave up and I went to
sleep so I might have missed the latter
half of convo it was fine honestly it
you know Andy he like q a q a q a
there's no rapid fire there's no real
conversation ever I watched Robin's
Island that's probably my biggest pet
peeve with it having said that last
night's episode I just needed answers
and it was literally question it was
like a toss back question answer
question answer and you know what it was
actually a good episode
yeah she looks great I enjoyed what I
watched up until it gave out has anybody
ever said or thought that Ariana Maddox
looks like Serena Kerrigan because when
she walked out I was like oh my God it
looked I literally thought it was
turning the car again good call right
and maybe it was just a hair up Serena
always wears her hair up like that with
the two pieces but I was just like oh my
God so I was just with Serena I was like
they don't not look alike they don't not
look alike
like I look like I'm like a look-alike
so we've got a great show
um programming update I think a lot of
people predicted this we're gonna move
to your toasters that we missed
yesterday because of the construction
let's do tomorrow when it's like low-key
today I need to just catch up like we
need to just chat yeah and it's already
late that would make that break up later
so we'll do it tomorrow and I feel good
about it on a Friday I feel good about
that too I just hope everyone whose
quandries are waiting like they can wait
one more day yeah hopefully there's
nothing urgent like timely yeah yeah how
was your night my night was look at me
over here just talking about myself
someone like me my night was lovely it
was low-key did you watch Banner from
girls live with commercials yes
most like we started maybe like eight
minutes in we paused a few times
Streisand had to go out so we watched
some of the commercials which was
actually nice I got to see that Bravo
commercial the Uber One commercial that
played every five minutes uh the
commercials like weren't bad somebody
was saying like and it gave me time to
like digest the last minutes of content
that I just saw because like I don't
know what I'm gonna say or the first
story is going to be obviously a recap
of the finale and all the news that's
come out I don't know what I have to say
about it because it was just a lot like
it wasn't like oh the tea was yeah it
wasn't
it's just emotional it was it felt wrong
to be watching such such things I
understand what you mean you know I
don't have a hot take to share yeah no
me neither I just like could not believe
what I was watching I know that that
that it happened
that you know they have to go and have
these conversations now
that we're seeing them so personal
I I
I really was just like in awe yeah I did
see um somebody on Twitter point out how
like the first before scannable broke
like the first couple episodes this
season the sponsors like the commercials
were like literally
um
like diet pills like literally
fraudulence and literally it was like
Clorox it was the best of the best Uber
Eats last night like premium Super Bowl
placement yeah because if I'm an
Advertiser I want to buy an ad on the
finale of Vanderpump Rules but you know
who got an add-in who Shannon bedore is
a little tincture company did you when I
was fast forwarding I saw her face can
you see like you know how she does her
ABS no but not QVC um you know she does
her the pictures yeah oh they not sold
on QVC that's something else that was
when she was doing meals right of frozen
meals yeah so yeah she has her little
like I saw her face when I was scrolling
so she got an ad I love the word
tincture I know I don't think I've ever
taken a tincture but I love attention I
think you should take a tincture and I
think it should be Shannon's tincture I
think maybe you should buy me a picture
I think that I will so you could leave
it in the studio and never open it
literally literally
um all right I feel like perhaps we
should just dive in perhaps we should
dive into the fast five stories that you
need to know today
and today's episode is brought to you by
Lululemon Lululemon was made to stretch
their shorts are flexible and supportive
and the infinite ways of work with the
infinite ways of working out they give
you the courage to LEAP into something
totally new and unexpected so their
hottie hot short is a short with a
comfortable range of motion and a
flattering fit they allow you to Max
your stride so you can move freely with
confidence their lightweight fabric lets
in airflow so you can move without
baggage and they're designed to Wick
away sweat before you even notice it's
there they also have the Wonder train
short the short with a super supportive
stretch that also keeps you dry they're
powered by the everlux fabric the Wonder
train collection manages heat and sweat
so use takes comfortable and focused so
the sweat wicking and quick drying
fabric absorbs more absorbs moisture and
Wicks sweat during even the most intense
training Lululemon is just a brand you
can trust like if you know you're going
to be out here working up a sweat
working nine to five you know that once
you get something from Lululemon the
quality is going to sustain itself all
the way through your journey they also
have the pace breaker shorts for men
they're a versatile short that is up to
any challenge their ultralight weight
fabric means you can train move and
stretch how you want without the baggage
I love all of the shorts from Lululemon
I really like the built-in Wick proof
material it's really really absorbent
even if you're not working out but
you're just a person who sweats it's
summer it's the summer not all of us
will be in our you know freezing cold
offices 24 7. it's really a nice touch
so you can get into the Lululemon shorts
at lululemon.com that's l-u-l-u
lemon.com lemon it's Wednesday lemon
it's a tincture today's episode is also
brought to you by modern fertility for a
lot of us the start of a new year feels
like the right time to schedule doctor's
appointments and check in with where
you're at health-wise but what about
your reproductive Health if you've
always been a big fan of planning ahead
like we have scheduling trips plotting
out career moves figuring out what
you're doing with kids is is a big one
I'm not gonna lie and that's why modern
fertility was created it's an easy and
affordable way to let your to test your
fertility hormones at home with a simple
finger prick mail it in with a prepaid
label and you'll get your personalized
results within six business days you'll
get insight into your hormone levels
like your ovarian reserve AKA if you
have more or fewer eggs than average
person your age you also get other
important factors that can impact your
fertility the results go deep into what
every hormone means so you can also
download the results with your doctor
for next steps traditional hormone
testing at a fertility clinic can cost
over six hundred dollars but modern
fertility tests the same general set of
hormones for only 179 and if you go to
modernfertility.com toast you can get 20
off your test it also can get reimbursed
for the test through your FSA or your
HSA so if you want kids today or maybe
someday in the future clinically sound
information about your body can help
make the decision that's right for you
right now modern fertility is offering
our listeners 20 off the test when you
go to modernfertility.com toast that
means your test will cost 159 which is a
fraction of what it would cost at a
fertility clinic get 20 off your
fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that's
modernfertility.com
t-o-a-s-t
t-o-a-s-t modernfertility.com toast okay
our first story Vanderpump Rules recap
we're going to talk about the episode
and then there's some like news stories
of things that people have said also
allegedly it came out yesterday that
they broke up right but then Ariana
addressed that on the show but let's
just go with what we saw last night the
Vanderpump Rules finale scandival
starting two days after that Watch What
Happens Live episode two days after
Ariana found the video on Tom's phone
camera started filming there were a few
moments I was actually really moved by
okay
um first Ariana telling us that Lisa
offered her a place to stay that was
very sweet yeah Ariana's showing up at
Lisa's house and just kind of like
collapsing in her arms like I'm this
episode actually really endeared me to
Lisa Vanderpump and I kind of understood
her role her role in the show has seemed
kind of irrelevant in recent years like
nobody really works at the restaurant
but she really is this like maternal
wise figure and I actually ended up like
really enjoying her presence on last
night's episode I also was really
endeared by the conversation
um not really conversation but just uh
Sheena sharing the anecdote about how
this is so hard for her you know
breaking up with Sandoval obviously and
I was like okay sure whatever Sheena but
then she was like no you know we've been
doing this for so long in the beginning
you really forget like nobody want to
cheat around they really tried to ice
her out of the show people I was
watching this morning while I was
getting ready they were playing old
episodes on Bravo they were so [__]
mean to her those girls like and like
ruthlessly like really evil and when
they were at the upfronts this big event
they were like these new starlets and
Danville really made it a point to
include her on the carpet like I
actually was moved by that and I thought
she wasn't being dramatic like crying
over her relationship with Sandoval I
didn't think she was being dramatic and
I actually thought it was really
necessary for Sheena to have a breakdown
given what we saw all season her blind
defense of Raquel against Katie who now
like Ariana's experiencing on a much
larger level exactly what Katie
experienced with Schwartz and Raquel
when like everybody made her like feel
so crazy and so I actually really felt
like I didn't even realize this but that
Sheena needed to have like this moment
of just like
the complete reversal of how she feels
about Raquel and how she feels about
Sandoval considering she was so wrong
and I felt like in her conversation with
Sandoval like like what she was saying
was very real and I appreciated how hard
it was for her yeah I also appreciated
like Brock taking summer to the park and
getting out of town you know yeah and
being like you put us in a bad position
bro I would go yeah
here's your package I also like not
Brock thinking that Sandoval brought
them a gift and he was like no he's
outside
um Brock was on what happens live in the
audience and Andy was like I love your
haircut he really does look so good he
does look so good I'm here for it yeah
I'm here for him in general and at this
stage like I'm obviously here for Sheena
but just watching this whole season back
like she did it did not look good for
her no she's really stupid
wrong on every count yeah like every
Hill she died on except maybe the hill
with like Katie and the wedding but
every other Hill but even that was
stemmed from Raquel but yes and that she
even overplayed with her hand with
saying like you can't come to the
preferred pool
I didn't actually don't think she
overplayed her hand like I know what we
know now like Katie didn't just decide
to take a vacation like Katie had to go
it was a cast trip like she had to go
she had no choice
um
say like you can't come to the preferred
pool like you don't own this hotel I
know but like
she shouldn't come to the preferred pool
you know what I mean yeah she shouldn't
want to go right but she shouldn't she
doesn't need to she shouldn't be kicked
off the premise like yeah yeah no and
sending Raquel was obviously like not
the greatest idea right
um so other points in the episode that
were highlights uh the one minute we got
of James Kennedy like I wish we got more
he's so funny like crazy how James and
Lala really weren't in the episode that
much considering like on social media
they were some of the loudest voices
yeah but I guess like as it pertains to
the storyline like they're really like
level C like it's like Tom Ariana and
Raquel the core then it's like really
Katie Schwartz Sheena yes then it's
everyone else well that's just like
James and Lala right right yeah Etc like
James is Raquel's ex yep and Lala is the
one who's been like pushing this narrow
that was the one who was right about her
yeah no for sure they really weren't in
a lot but that scene at their apartment
like was funny yeah it was crazy it's
crazy that James just like called her up
just to yell at her shocked she picked
up yeah and then the the kind of big
scene there were so many Big scenes I
know one of the big scenes was Raquel's
apartment with Tom and I think everyone
like collectively clenched their
buttholes when he was talking about his
family say you know they love you and
she thought he said I love you and she
was like I love you too
yeah but it's nice to know they're in
love and that they and that they say it
to each other I don't know I feel like a
lot of the excitement and and
potentially I don't think that they're
broken up I think that report is false
but if they are broken up I feel like
you know part of the excitement with an
affair is you know the salaciousness of
it all and doing it behind like knowing
it's wrong and then when that kind of uh
I literally can't relate to that like no
including knowing it's wrong makes it
not fun for me kill me but that is like
what happens some like crazy people feel
yeah right and I think for Tom who's a
clearly chasing some sort of high in his
life I think the the rebellious nature
of the romance is probably what Drew him
to it a lot and once once that's over
you know you're left with the person in
front of you and I don't know if there
is this like deep romantic perfect match
connection between the two of them and I
could almost feel him like last night
just being like
like not as excited about it anymore
they keep talking about him we have this
deep connection and then he gets there
and it was like yeah I know they were
holding back for the cameras but it
wasn't didn't seem like this great love
like I don't know I felt more like a
real love in a relationship to me than I
thought it was going to especially since
they were like saying things like just
because I I've never seen them like
together like that
so them like agreeing that it's like
weird to be in front of cameras and and
do what they do I felt like
they have that relationship I think the
rebellious nature of it definitely is
attractive for them but I also think you
know
it's the newness for Tom like he likes
things that are shiny new and I think
even if he's able to have like a real
relationship brother Raquel will be new
for a while and he will still be into it
like it was with Ariana a point yeah but
he also like I think the the hovering
theme Here is that he's 40 and he's
having a serious mid-life crisis yeah
like it's crazy that he's 40 and he's
going to his girlfriend's apartment with
the lights the Galaxy Light it's so
stupid it's so childish so childish
immature and he has no idea who he is
they're perfect for each other because
she has no idea who she is no that's so
true and what's just so crazy to me is
why Ariana was so ride or die for him I
know no matter how bad their
relationship it's it's admirable but why
right like we found out last night at
night she knew about Miami girl so this
is somebody who has cheated on I don't
understand forgiveness
I that doesn't even shock me so much but
he doesn't come home at night you guys
don't have a good relationship like you
don't have an intimate relationship like
what is there like and he's also a
[__] loser and she's cool so like
what does she admire about him yeah no
I'm not sure but you know you get
comfortable and like you just things
work and they're fine like that's what
happens to a lot of people and so for
sure like Tom's not wrong and saying
like this relationships should have
ended
sure I think probably they both would
have agreed with that yeah like this is
not how you do it no oh my God no no not
at all and I I will be curious for the
reunion like to hear because Tom said on
the show a few times to different people
including Ariana that he tried to break
up with her yeah and that there were
different responses of like literally no
yep um she threatened to kill herself
herself like so um she said he never
tried to break up with her right so I I
want to see them have that conversation
yeah well so that's how the reunion is
laid out I think it's
Tom and Ariana solo Tom Ariana Raquel
big group without Raquel with Sheena big
group without China with Raquel wow
that's how I think it goes yeah and
they're not talking about the rest of
the season they're not no I saw um in
our the
um one of the producers was like talking
about casting they're not they're not
filming yet they're taking like a a
minute to sort out their casting stuff
because they're in kind of a tough spot
nobody will film with Tom and Raquel
obviously but Tom and Raquel are the
story oh yeah no but so I can't believe
we've gotten this far without talking
about Schwartz
like at this whole time he's always been
this person he's always been this loser
who would like do anything for his loser
friend who doesn't respect his wife like
he's always been this person but for
some reason like he's gotten away with
it he's got away with it the fan is like
the fans are like oh shorts is so cute
myself included it wasn't until this
season like even in the last few weeks
that I've come to despise him I've
actually always thought he was like cute
puppy dog and Deering right sweet means
well nice guy right and so I think he's
really having some sort of identity
crisis like he was just beloved and he
could act like an animal and he did and
he would make poor choices he cheated on
Katie remember he made out of the girl
but everyone was sure it's easier it's
easy and two in a dime like have like
all the consequences of your actions
like show up at your front door in this
huge way like he's really struggling and
the way he won't even slightly like be
angry at Sandoval is so psychotic to me
yeah well he he said a little bit when
he spoke to Ariana that he's upset
no no he didn't say to Sanibel and now
we could see how that first apology note
from his way and it's just like Schwartz
being so [__] dumb to really like I
understand that his business is
suffering and that must be hard and
really the hardest part like yes
everybody's feelings are hurt but I'm
sure on a personal level for Schwartz
like his parents or his family invested
in it he invested he lost his marriage
over it he has people working a lot of
credit
everything is on the line for him and
that is like aside from you know getting
hate tweets and mean comments like
that's [__] that's real I get that
yeah but he doesn't even have like the
self-awareness to be like Sandoval you
need to put out a statement like
about the situation not just about the
business no they're just like and I
remember it when it happened like they
were just panicked about the business
and I do think in the end
this ultimately will be a good thing for
the business I don't think like the
destruction of the business like it's
going to be collateral because at the
end of the day like it is the setting
now behind like one of the greatest most
scandalous reality TV moments in history
like I do think it will end up being
like a good thing for the restaurant I
don't know
he said on what should have inside that
people are like coming in mostly to you
know like and I think Schwartz like
shows up every day and like sits down
with people and talks about it just to
like give them an experience like you
know it's like come to shorts and
standards if you want to talk to me
about scanners like Lala's selling merch
right selling himself right
um which isn't like the worst idea I've
ever heard but
I don't know if like their restaurant
can withstand like this period of
boycott yeah yeah but is the period
still going on I felt like it was over I
feel like it's still going on this like
the episode just aired right
and then we're gonna have reunion like I
don't know what's going on over there I
will say like major kudos to Bravo I
think they've really handled the whole
thing very well kind of embargoing you
know Ariana until tonight and then she
was on The Today Show this morning I
thought the editing in the beginning of
the episode was excellent Ben was on the
edge of his [__] seat he couldn't
believe it he was also cackling at
everything Tom Schwartz said like he was
like this guy is so dumb Schwartz yeah
like everything that just came out of
his mouth really he doesn't think like
how is this next sentence going to make
me look yeah because he's just so he
said what comes to mind and people have
loved it eaten it up yeah
but no the chickens are coming home to
ruse like bed was cracking up when he
got to Katie's he was like can I have a
Coke and she was like yeah sure and he
took a beer like like little dumb things
like that which is really like what
people have loved about Schwartz this
whole time but it's just not [__]
cute anymore no like it's annoying no
no
um what else I felt like the the initial
conversation you know the sit-down of
the century between Ariana and Tom who
are still living in the same house it's
so crazy crazy but you know me and Ben
were having this conversation like they
split that house right and they put all
their Vanderpump money into this house
like who I'm not [__] leaving yeah
she shouldn't leave because he should
leave but if he's not leaving like she
should go stay with a friend like she
said Lisa right offered Sheena had
Raquel staying with her at one point
like there's a million places she could
go I'm sure she's gotten reached out to
by literally everyone Hotel
Airbnb should really oh by the way
marketing idea for Airbnb give her a
house at your house this crazy lunatic
leaves that's actually a very good idea
it's insane that she's in the same house
as him it's nuts and when they sat down
for that conversation I actually thought
she was much more measured and you know
calm even though you know she wasn't
that calm then I would have been like I
thought she she really had an she took
the time to think about what she wanted
to say and like sometimes you know what
you want to say but your emotions just
Cloud everything and she was crystal
[__] clear yeah it was a great time
in her grieving process to have the
conversation because it was just
straight anger facts and then like when
she goes over to Lisa she can just fall
apart
um when Tom went over to Lee says that
I'm sorry like I was not [__] okay
cracking up this man I don't know like
he's so weird looking like in this
current ERA with his floppy hair and his
mustache and the nail polish and like
the punk rock outfits like he's so
unserious and he thinks he's a rock star
and so he's like having this fake panic
attack like cry breakdown I think it was
fake uh Beyond like
I'm sorry it was so it was fake I just
want to say it doesn't mean I feel sorry
for him I just want to say I don't think
it was fake and I think to go through I
think a part of him is enjoying all the
attention attention um a part of him is
like he ruined his life what is he gonna
do to go through what he's gone through
and not break down at one point point
and have a panic attack
um would be
psychotic I'm sorry I actually take it
back I don't think it was fake I just
don't think he was crying about what he
said he was crying about I don't think
there's really any love lost for for him
to Ariana I think he's crying about the
fact that like his band is in trouble
and yeah his situation like oh people
don't like me and he's just crazy
narcissist he's not crying because this
is the last conversation he might ever
have with Ariana you don't give a [__]
no no no no no no he's crying because
his world has imploded right and he hit
the button and he was really able to act
like such an ass for so long but like
for some reason like the Bravo fans
lived for it and he was able to like
open this restaurant and be Lisa's
number one and get Tom Tom and start the
band like he was able to do all this
even as the worst
so we just took the worst like a little
too far this time he didn't know where
where he could take it yeah
it was crazy it was honestly historic
Ariana was so beautiful and really just
very well spoken very measured on
watched weapons live Andy was eating it
up it was it was just historic yeah it
was it was really crazy what'd you think
of Kristen coming back I needed more I
mean she's so mature and you know Ariana
like had you know started to apologize
because you know how you get him is how
you lose him and Kristen didn't even
want to hear it yeah she's so mature
she's so lovely I off camera a lot of
them are really good friends with Chris
so many of the fans were like this they
you know were healing like that the fact
that Kristen and Ariana were hugging but
like they're very close such good
friends for such a long time like this
isn't new no so it wasn't crazy it
wasn't like this has brought them
together at all no I did cringe like my
face off when at the end they were like
ashes to ashes dust to dust no matter
the day we choose to Slay
Slay we must so we must I was like
passing away me and Ben were like
no I know and they're just like choogy
Millennials but like it was too much
like it was actually too much I totally
agree slay we must yeah
I actually like I needed to go to the
hospital it was so painful
ambulance for me
I also thought it was really interesting
that Ariana
um has been watching so much tick tock
really she said I don't watch I'm live
and she also said it today on The View
that's how it is crazy to me no but
she's getting like she's like I'm
literally being targeted with like all
this content about myself like people
making like music videos and she's like
it's just weird that's funny yeah but
it's probably also helpful for her
because they're probably pulling up old
scenes that she's seeing and she's able
to like contextualize them now and be
like oh [__] yeah Andy was also like you
know at the end of the day like all this
crazy this was like the last question so
you probably didn't hear it all this
crazy stuff like endorsements there's
talks of her being on Dancing With the
Stars you're going on The View in the
Today show
um like all in all net net
you okay yeah and she was like it's
really crazy like she didn't want to say
but like I you know what I it actually
made me think about all the girls whose
best friends sleep with their boyfriends
and don't get to go on Dancing With the
Stars like the situation probably
remedied itself like she was too booked
and busy and famous and popular to
really spend that much time being down
like almost immediately she was out here
she's in an ad campaign for
Bloomingdale's like there's all this
stuff she's on Comedy Central like
I don't really feel like she could have
been that sad after that no I agree and
it's like before scandaval she's in like
a misery an admitted miserable
relationship disconnected from The
Biggest Loser in the world and she's
always been like a constant on the show
but never the star or anything and I
also don't think that's that important
to her but like because she would be
crazier if it was but so that's where
she was before scandival yeah okay so
your best friend betrayed you and slept
with your life that's really [__]
terrible but you are the biggest star in
the world everybody loves you every door
is open to everybody supports you you
every like your universe and nobody is
you are universally loved but I guess
like if you think about it like before
she even though Sandoval sucks and we
hate him like she thought like and she
doesn't have a lot of
um like close family I think yeah
um well she has her mom and her brother
she's such as I'm sorry Sheena red uh
Tom Sandoval to absolutely when he was
like she said she was going to kill
herself which Ariana says is not true
what was I supposed to do and she's like
you call me you call Jeremy you called
you fly Tanya in like she had the
[__] answers I'm like yes she is so
true it was a perfect answer but I feel
like she only has like a few close
people in her life so like she thought
she had that with Tom even though you
know it wasn't the spiciest most
exciting relationship after nine years
it was stable it was like you you had
what you thought was loyalty in your man
and your best friend and to lose that
even though you could go on Dancing With
the Stars yeah like none of that really
matters it like kind of shakes you to
your core yeah I will say there were
some things that came out of Tom
Sandoval's mouth last night that I found
like genuinely shocking like even for a
narcissistic [__] side psychopath
like such as
why don't you tell her well I just
figured she'd follow me and figure it
out oh my God that was crazy that that
was like a Next Level sub-human to even
conjure up a thought like that
diabolically following him up on his
lies but also but by the way he was
lying about a lot but he wasn't lying
about going to Schwartz how much of
their Affair was taking place at
Schwartz's no I think that it was well
Ariana said when he said that I was
shocked because I was looking at his
location and he was at Schwartz's oh
that's crazy with Raquel with Raquel but
he could also just go to Raquel's right
but I guess like not as frequently he
was hiding something so he was doing
like a decent job of covering it up yeah
no it's also it's like if you want to
get caught which is what it sounds like
when you say follow me then why are you
deleting everything off your phone but
she says let me look at your phone there
you go oops sorry so much of the [__]
like when he started to yell at her in
the opening scene I'm like you sit down
that's even if you have thoughts you sit
down and you just [__] take it it's
crazy that in like the first
second of like there's gonna be waves of
this and maybe at like wave five he
could retaliate explain
where he was at you know like because I
do want to know like mentally how did we
get his place but in wave one you sit
there and you [__] take it and you
just say sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry but he's such a narcissist like
you could true and he really is like a
true narcissist true narcissist can
really only apologize and take
accountability like if at all a very
limited amount like until they're like
well I was wrong right I feel like I
deserve love and a deep connection like
he's incapable of swallowing his pride
and just being wrong yeah because he
really is honestly not okay no and now I
want to talk about this rumor that they
broke up okay so there's how she's
locked up she's sending him letters
Ariana said it is locked up so I just
want to say like there was chapter time
we were all kind of wrong we thought she
just went to a retreat Canyon Ranch
she's sending snail now she's in a
facility she's in a facility so if she
can't even like talk to him on the phone
she's sending him letters they ain't
breaking up unless I had a thought last
night that the letter that came to him a
few days ago said Tom we have to end
things oh
well here's the thing I I think about
how this could play out in future
Seasons this upcoming season
specifically and
if Raquel and Tom break up
I can see a world in which Raquel kind
of positions herself she's just in this
facility positions herself as like a
victim of Tom Sandoval and maybe in a
very long time and in a very slow way
she slowly makes her way back to the
group as like an outsider and Tom
Sandoval becomes the sole villain of
this Saga I don't think so I think I
don't think Tom Sandoval will ever come
back from this
I don't I couldn't predict which one
would but the only thing that would
bring him back is the fact that they
have like a history you know it's been
15 years like Sheena said like with
Raquel they've known this [__] three
years and it turns out nothing turned
they didn't know where they owe her
nothing so I I could see I think she'll
go that route I think that's really the
only road to go down if they do break up
that like that she was a victim of his
yeah but I don't think it's gonna work
for anyone no those girls are hardened
they're better off just falling in love
yeah no that's what I'm saying so it
when they are like it it will be so
weird if they just dissolve and break up
and it was like all of this was for
nothing
yeah I also felt like last night they
did a really good job of like kind of
explaining how deep so many of these
relationships go like I totally forgot
Ariana was a groomsman yeah like and I
thought when she sat him down and her
being so clear like I will not associate
with one person that is friends with him
so you and I are done have a nice life
like I think that hey that's really
healthy b it was very like Savage of her
but then I watched Evans live he was
like what about Lisa
and like the the relationships they're
not friends like she said I want him
mutual friends with him but like it's
not a friendship that they have and I do
think that I I don't fault Lisa for
Lending an ear no to Tom Sandoval and
it's not like she's like saying patting
him on the back she's giving him hard
truths like that doesn't really bother
me so no me neither but it's also like
lala literally said the same thing this
season about like Randall and Tom
Schwartz and how come that wasn't met
with such acceptance yep yep yep yep
like Randall's uh an actual like alleged
deviant right
um and nobody respected that and nobody
respected that it's like oh Lalas are
being intense one other thing I will say
that I really liked was the complete
breaking of the fourth wall
they talked about the fact that they're
on a show they have fans they're famous
there's press there's US Weekly to a
degree they talked about it but I also
like that they didn't that I actually
feel like they they punctured the fourth
Ball but they didn't completely break it
which I like they were honest about
certain things but like we're still
filming a show and they're still
assembling so but like the elephant in
the room it's like we're all stars like
they don't really talk about that ever
like they're just supposed to be like
normal people in weho it was helpful
yeah it was extremely well done yeah it
was sad
it was sad no I'm telling you like I
wasn't like lapping it up oh I was also
shook that we got one scene with Raquel
I thought there would be a little bit
more
it literally when that screen came up
and said she turned off her phone
nobody's heard from her for weeks I was
shocked especially since she she seemed
decently comfortable in the filming
setting like yeah but she wasn't
terrible we heard and reported that they
that he went to her apartment and they
filmed like the idea I had of what they
filmed would have been like her like in
a corner like this like no she was
herself and she was making jokes and
smiling and being like you know I have
no friends
um the scar is visible yeah that is a
scar and it's a nail it's literally a
half moon shape yeah it's a summer moon
shape I actually believed sheena's
explanation of it like she might have
just cut her with her like she didn't I
don't think she pulled her arm back and
wound up and punched her I I believe
sheena's explanation but Raquel did have
a mark uh visible a wound and it was
also visible in her interview when she's
covered with makeup yeah but she only
had like a two second interview why did
they only show they got like no Rock
hell footage no but like she went and
sat down for an interview and they only
included like one sound bite and also
what the [__] else did she say think
about that time period as well she was
like doing TMZ and then she filmed the
reunion like there actually was decent
amount of time where before she went
M.I.A she did the TMZ like literally two
days before the reunion I think but she
sat down on a green screen for an
interview
showed us one clip what and one clip was
like crazy yeah what else did she say I
don't know
I just I want to see that interview
and Raquel as we know it is still in
this facility yeah
it's crazy so do you think they broke up
no no not unless the letter had said
that right but I feel like the letter
could have said that if she really like
is doing deep if the therapy facility
accomplishes what it said what did you
accomplish she should break up with him
right yeah and that would come in the
form of a letter D
[Music]
I see it all now that I'm
gone don't you think 28's too young to
be played by your Dark Twisted games
when you when I loved you
so I gotta go I think that's what it
said I think that's what it says too
well it's not over yet we have three
parts for you Michael's version
literally that's our title today
remember it also there was a little more
there was a couple more headlines that I
just wanted to make sure that we talked
about okay I thought the most
interesting tidbit from the episode
was LaLa claiming that Tom Sandoval
cheated with Billy
with Billy Lee thank you so much for
bringing that up and I'm watch Robin's
live he pressed her about it he was like
who is this person who's the third
person that you you know the infidelity
about she said it's somebody in Bravo no
she didn't say Bravo she said not in the
show universe but he said Is it someone
in the Bravo Universe She said not the
show universe and Andy's never met them
makes me think it's like some sort of
influencer or something I need to know I
need to because Annie's met Billy right
because Billy was at a reunion right but
then also very recently Sandoval was
Paparazzi with Billy yeah they're
friends there's something there there's
something there that wasn't there before
and the fact that that came up at a
reunion it was unaired footage what you
show us crap it's so true even though
she was like no truth to the rumor like
the fact that there's a rumor going
around about two cast members
like let us know I was floored by that
Revelation and that footage and I'm
gonna need more yeah I'm gonna need Lala
to explain herself investigates yeah
just explain what you meant when you
said that yep
explain what you meant question mark
exclamation and I don't think it was
just one person I think it was just the
one person that's confirmed Miami girl
yeah he's a liar
Sandoval's a liar and then Raquel
as far as we know I thought that was no
I'm so glad you brought that out
uh and that's it but it's but it's so
not it it's not it we have three weeks
three more weeks of reunion and I can't
wait yeah same
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you
[Music]
introducing the bed by fuma handcrafted
from eco-friendly high quality upcycled
wood the bed from thuma has a modern
minimalist design that helps Elevate any
space it's super supportive for your
mattress it's breathable and it's made
to naturally minimize noise and create
space the bed is put together using the
Timeless technique of Japanese joinery
each piece locks into place meaning no
tools or excess Hardware are required
for assembly with clean lines subtle
curves and lifestyle enhancing details
the bed is simple sophistication for the
bedroom now Jackie I know you're the
owner a proud owner of a thumabed proud
owner tell us all about it the process
the journey the process I'm so happy to
say was so unremarkable in the sense
that it was extremely quick no fights
broke out and we have this gorgeous bed
so when you're putting together
Furniture you don't want it to be a
memorable experience it's never going to
be memorable for a good reason so true
it's going to be a fight that you guys
are always going to cite yeah reference
and next time you go Furniture shopping
you're going to be like is it going to
be like you know the bed assembly of
2018 with Summa there's none of that
they're keeping beds together and
relationships together with their easy
to assemble Japanese joinery Summa is
backed with a lifetime warranty it ships
right to your door in three easy to
maneuver boxes and takes about five
minutes to set up with no tools required
super easy to build yourself create that
feeling of checking into your favorite
boutique hotel suite but at home with
the bed by thuma and now go to thuma.co
toast to receive a 25 credit towards
your purchase of the bed plus free
shipping in the continental US go to
thuma.co toast that's t-h-u-m-a dot Co
slash t-o-a-s-t for a 25 credit today's
episode is also brought to you by
kariyuma and Jax is wearing her carrying
my shoes today you've been wearing them
all week carry Uma
um
Carry carry um so carry Uma is the cool
sustainable sneaker company made for
life on and off the board warmer days
are ahead and we all need a staple shoe
to carry us through the summer and
Beyond when it comes to days spent in
the sunshine and on your feet carry um
has got you covered with effortless
style unmatched comfort and premium
quality worn by celebrities like Ashton
Kutcher and Jackie ashtray and Jackie
ashra and praised by Publications like
Vogue and GQ so Jax tell me about your
carrying him with shoes as a pregnant
lady you need full support you do I got
them a few weeks ago I've been wearing
them every single day on the show I've
gotten a lot of questions like what are
these shoes Jax is wearing and I wanted
to wait to share until we could share
our code because we do have one for you
guys and they're just so cute and
stylish like yesterday I was wearing a
polished outfit and they worked today
I'm wearing a cozy outfit and they work
they're just the shoe that you need in
your closet you do
um the kariyuma company is B Corp
certified and has a dedicated
restoration program based in the
Brazilian Rainforest so you know for
every pair of sneakers sold carium is
planting two trees and they've already
planted over 2 million trees to date
they ship their sneakers free and fast
in the USA and they offer worldwide
shipping and 60-day free returns they
deliver right to your door using single
box recycled packaging and for a limited
time like Jackie said we do have a code
toast listeners can get an exclusive 15
off your pair of carry Uma sneakers when
they go to kariyuma.com toast carriuma
is spelled
c-a-r-i-u-m-a.com slash toast for 50 off
for a limited time carry uma.com toast
thank you Claudia welcome our next story
is a kind of layered okay because
yesterday a report came out that shaken
Meghan Markle and Prince Harry were
involved in a near fatal Paparazzi Chase
in New York city so Prince Harry and
Meghan Markle are extremely upset and
shaken after being involved in a near
catastrophic two-hour Paparazzi Chase in
New York City on Tuesday night after the
event that we talked about yesterday
where she was looking gorgeous and he
was looking greatly
where she got her award for the women of
vision
um the due conductors of Sussex who were
traveling with Megan's mom Doria were
pursued by photographers after leaving
the ziegfield theater the trio left the
event in an SUV around 10 pm and were
immediately followed by around 12
paparazzi paparazzi page six is told
they eventually decided to ditch their
original vehicle and jump into a Yellow
Cab in hopes of evading photogs of
source claims The Insider alleges that
one cameraman hit a car while another
almost ran over an NYPD officer during
the near quote near fatal chase it
started off with 12 Paparazzi then ended
up with four chasing chasing Harry
Maggie that's a cute couple yeah it is
Megan Harry and Doria their security
tried their best to lose the
photographers once in the taxi Harry
used his cell phone to record the
ensuing Malay we're told security was
also recording to gather evidence
Paparazzi were confronted by uniformed
police officers but ignored warnings and
continued racing the Cheerio we hear
um then a rep for the sussex's claim
that last night the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex and Miss Ragland were involved in
a near catastrophic car chase at the
hands of a ring of Highly aggressive
Paparazzi this Relentless Pursuit
lasting over two hours resulted in
multiple near collisions involving other
drivers on the road pedestrians and two
NYPD officers while being a public
figure comes with a level of interest
from the public it should never come at
the cost of anyone's safety I agreed so
that's a obviously harrowing well
especially like hello we were all here
like his mother died in a car car chase
with Paparazzi so it feels very like
history repeating itself energy yes so
then yesterday more details were coming
out about the um the chase a few
different uh
people spoke on it who were involved the
mayor the mayor who's not involved the
but the mayor loves a celebrity you know
he's getting involved no you know he's
getting involved we'll share what he
said the NYPD put out a statement and
the taxi driver and that's who I want to
hear from uh gave a video interview I
will say like I know they got they got
into like their armored tinted cars and
they couldn't shake four of the 12
Paparazzi I don't think getting into a
Yellow Cab without tinted windows and
with an untrained driver like to evade
Paparazzi you have to it's a specific
trait like Yes actually New York City
cab drivers are some of the best drivers
in the world but it's still not the
skill I don't think that was the wisest
decision no so I mean I understand why
they did it we always say too like if
people want to draw attention to
themselves like don't come with armored
vehicles yeah exactly so they were in
their car and they were being pursued
and they went to a police precinct on
67th Street and where they like filed
this complaint and waited it out and
then their security guard held them a
taxi to take them the rest of the way
it's taxi being less um
conspicuous than their vehicle but the
taxi driver said so the taxi driver
started to drive and Paparazzi spotted
them was taking pictures of them so they
asked the taxi driver to Circle back to
the precinct so that they could go back
there the taxi driver was there anyone
in the cab with them or just three three
of them I think by the
security guy maybe they were in other
vehicles maybe he said he picked up
Harry Megan and an older woman he didn't
recognize
um and a security guard sorry security
guard in his Yellow Cab at about 11 pm
outside the New York police precinct on
East 67th Street they were saying uptown
um and he said that he got the
impression from the group that they had
already been pursued by the paparazzi
before entering his car after a few
minutes the security guard grew
concerned about the photographers around
them and asked him to return to the
police station because they got cut off
by a garbage truck this is just New York
City too what they were driving and a
garbage trust so what happened and they
can't move and so then there's Paparazzi
oh they were like that's just
unfortunate next to them taking pictures
the guards thought they were too exposed
and didn't want their location shared
more widely he turned and headed north
of Madison Avenue driving back to the
pickup point he estimated the journey
wasn't in 10 minutes he said though I
don't think I would call it a Chase I
never felt like I was in danger it
wasn't like a car chase in a movie they
were quiet and seemed scared but it's
New York it's safe plus if you're a New
Yorker you know that there's not
anywhere to go it is quite it is
physically impossible for a car chase to
occur in the streets of New York maybe
on the FDR or the West Side Highway but
it is physically impossible the streets
are tiny like there's always double
parked cars there's nowhere to drive
like you can't go to an over 20 miles an
hour in New York city so let alone a two
hour car chase a car chase they might
have been being followed and I'm sure
that they were but a car chase is you
know we all think OJ yeah but I think
the whole ordeal was two hours from the
time they left it yeah then to the time
they got to their destination I will say
it wasn't like two hours of cars ripping
through the streets right right causing
each other Mayhem I will say the
paparazzi are so out of control and like
really so disrespectful and like nothing
they get is Ever Enough
having said that it sounds like a lot of
bad calls were made by her security
detail I cannot imagine why anybody
thought it would be a good idea to put
her in a Yellow Cab when there's still
Paparazzi around the one thing all right
if Paparazzi are following you you're in
your armored tinted vehicle they can't
get a photo of you like so I don't like
that's just a horrible idea and then to
go back to the precinct and to get out
of the car twice along right this
honestly like it sounds like a bunch of
morons are in charge of them honestly
like that's really dumb yes oh and to go
to the precinct
period you're in the do you know how
hard it is for them all to get in the
car with the paparazzi they're in the
car just go home someone could go to the
precinct for you you could file a report
you can call the police I'm sure they
have special connections to the police
to get out of the car Midway like that's
that's just bad security maybe they
didn't know what Paparazzi didn't know
where they were staying so to make it to
their I'm sure Paparazzi already knows
where they're staying okay well mayor
Adams then said in a press conference on
Wednesday it's clear that the press the
paparazzi they want to get the right
shot but Public Safety must always be at
the Forefront he was especially
concerned that two of their police
officers could have been injured and
said while he found it quote hard to
believe that there was a two-hour
high-speed chase even an incident
lasting 10 minutes could have been
extremely dangerous no by the way I am
sure like I don't think anyone's lying
like I'm sure that like they're really
hyper sensitive hypersensitive to given
the mom given the situation even when we
watch Harry and Megan the documentary
there was a scene where they're like on
the West Side Highway and there's
Paparazzi that are following them as
Paparazzi do and they are visibly shaken
by it but like and it's just an
unfortunate byproduct of being a public
figure you know like when the
Kardashians come to New York they are
hounded and I think they expect like a
lot of really big like the biggest names
experience this all the time but it it's
different for Harry given his history of
course with the media and the cars right
so I don't think that they're lying but
I do think they're probably like I don't
even think they're intentionally
dramatizing it because to them it was
probably
so traumatizing and like so real but
like the facts but you know we say this
as somebody who wasn't there you know
I'm sure I'd be freaked out too no but
like
I just I was just watching Kardashians
Hulu and Kim goes to Miami and they're
like pulled up at a red light and uh uh
there's Paparazzi everywhere so I and
there's car Paparazzi and there's yeah
uh on their foot Paparazzi and bike
Paparazzi and I'm sure that's exactly
what this was it just it's different
when Harry's experiencing it because he
is so traumatized when I heard the story
I was actually thinking because we
haven't seen any sort of relationship
between Meghan Markle and the
Kardashians
um and actually based on what she said
about like Housewives and feminism on
her podcast I feel like she'd probably
hate the Kardashians but they could
probably help her like they are probably
like the queens of Paparazzi and letting
the paparazzi see them when they want
and when they don't want and they have
all whenever I'm watching the show I'm
always like shook it like just these
little things that they do and you know
what I'm sure they could actually like
swap info and I think they would
probably be helpful but I feel like I
just get the vibe she just probably
doesn't like them
I feel like they've met and it just like
didn't click click because like they
were both at Ellen's birthday party
that's the most recent thing yeah and I
do feel like Kim and Megan would have
things they would be friends for the
fact that they're not is because like
they're not right and also Megan just
hired one of Kim's former security
guards we always know as lay people
where the Kardashians are saying when
they come to New York because they take
pictures outside their hotel like I
think that's just the fact that they've
accepted but it's about the security
that they have the hotel of the hotel
you know they the people in on the
ground in the rooms like yes I agree
they could maybe learn something you
know like I just feel like the
Kardashians are honestly like of all the
famous people right now probably the
most well-versed in Paparazzi culture
and security because yeah because of Kim
exactly yes so this was like everyone
coming out of the woodwork to tell their
side of the story the cab driver the
mayor I was like cracking up backward
photo agency is put out a scene that
um that they were in danger during this
car chase these paparazzis were being
animals like I'm look I've seen footage
like they're animals yeah but I'm sure
you know to Harry and Megan it also it's
been worse than it is because it's
heightened exactly it's heightened
yeah I agree yeah
so that was crazy that was crazy
are speeding and in danger and they're
about to hit a police officer and about
to hit pedestrians like ticket them
right stop them in their tracks right
right no yeah right yeah
it's like literally the least shocking
thing that this mayor spoke out like he
is obsessed with celebrity honestly it's
like the one thing I kind of relate to
him on like he's so thirsty goes to the
opening of an envelope like he's
unbelievably thirsty and so the two
literally the biggest most famous people
in the country right now we're in your
city and said something happen with your
Police Department like press conference
I'm here it's honestly like a sitcom
like yes uh
um Parks and Rec yep yup yup yup are you
ready for our next story yeah a little
bit of information about The Saga
between Kim and Croy what a report says
that Kim is demanding Kroy Biermann be
tested for drugs and she fears for the
kids safety oh I really never got that
vibe from him marijuana
oh my God the drama Kim is accusing a
strange husband Corey Bierman I'm having
a drug problem according to court
documents obtained by TMZ on Wednesday
she reportedly filed a petition
requesting that the former NFL player
submitted drug test amid their ongoing
divorce the procedure would include a
five panel hair follicle drug screen per
the report according to TMZ Kim has
allegedly witnessed Croy smoking
marijuana and has concerns about the
safety of their four minor children oh
my God he's going off the deep end
according to Legal experts weed is not
legal in the state of Georgia where the
exes reside also like there are degrees
of marijuana so I'm smoking a blunt once
like right after a long day but if she's
going to split custody with him and he's
high every single day you don't want
your kids around that do could be
addicted to pot yes okay yes have you
never met someone who's addicted I don't
think I have you don't know that many
people though but yeah rude no pot is
extremely addictive and then it's also
like degenerative for your life yeah
because it's like it's like a slow yeah
like once in a while yeah you want to
kick back together right right if you're
doing that every single day like I could
understand as a a parent that's not the
environment yeah you're kidding so it
there are so many degrees to what this
story could be
but I found that interesting yeah no I
mean the headline is misleading I'm like
oh he's railing lines and projecting
heroin you know of all the drugs to be
doing but they're in the midst of a
cutsci battle so you do kind of Sling
anything you can no and you use the
person like the worst not that smoking
pot is a bad thing about you but in the
eyes of the law you're going to use
everything you got because you want to a
make your partner look worse and make
you look best so you can get a favorable
custody but you could have legitimate
concerns about your kids being in
custody of someone who is recreationally
right doing drugs I'm gonna think it's
probably like a strategic legal move as
opposed to like him being strung out on
pot honestly
I don't know me neither
but I just never got like the vibe from
him that he's like well clearly
something's changed one of them or both
of them but like as a father he's like
so active you know like let's go play
football like I don't see him as like
hey let's sit on the couch and be
potatoes like he was always trying to
get the kids like in the pool at the
golf like he's very he's an active he's
an athlete yeah and of course I'm
talking about a TV show so I don't know
the person and this was five years ago
but that's just based on you know my my
research what you've seen yeah but we
haven't seen things in a few years no we
haven't so we don't know what's going on
we don't
maybe you know cameras need to roll in
order for me to make a decision he got
into marijuana and he and he can't get
out of it yeah slippery slope it is a
gateway drug it's a real thing to like
if you smoke every single day yeah you
do know people who smoke every single
day actually I do yes but they like to
me they don't seem like addicted like
when I think addicted I think like
rehab do people go to rehab for pot no
because I don't think it's taken that
seriously and I also think like
typically if you're like addicted to pot
it's not just pot like it winds up being
something yes like stuff too pills or
yeah yeah no that's fair so I don't know
that many people you don't so I am a
woman no actually you know a lot of
people not on like a personal level I
guess yeah
I just feel like I have a lot like uber
like I have so many friends
I have a million friends like just ask
scuba my best day
are you ready for our next our next
story no no is it the story that's
brought to you by bigger than Beauty yes
all right bigger than Beauty skincare so
Thrive Cosmetics the brand that you guys
know we love the award-winning mascara
they just launched a new skincare brand
dedicated to making conscientious
Innovative vegan products that blend
nourishing ingredients for a powerful
impact so their products feature
dermatologists recommended formulas that
deliver transformative results I love
that it's like a brand that we know and
trust starting a skincare brand because
skincare is like tough you know it all
looks good and then you look at the
ingredients and it's like trash but
Thrive Cosmetics is a brand that we use
lip products eye products from and so
them creating skin care is fabulous
because we know we can trust it so here
are some of their fabulous products that
I'm loving Gel Cleanser I love a gel
cleanser I love Gel Cleanser so their
Rich Gel Cleanser removes daily
impurities waterproof makeup and it
leaves your skin feeling hydrated and
balanced they also have the liquid
brilliant super serum it is instantly
brightening your skin with a blend of
vitamins and plant extracts for a
healthier looking glowy complexion it's
packed with high potency blend of
niacinamide and amino acids and it
visibly Smooths the look of fine lines
and brightens dullness
um they also have the defying Defying
Gravity eye lifting cream so it has
green tea and caffeine in it it will
visibly reduce the appearance of
dullness darkness dark circles puffiness
and it'll give you firmer brighter skin
under your eye area which can always be
a really kind of thin layer of skin and
just look decrepit if you don't take
care of it
um it's a good choice it's
a good choice for your skin but also for
your routine you can simplify your skin
care regimen with products that deliver
Real Results more efficiently simplify
your routine amplify your impact with
the brand new skin care that's bigger
than Beauty get 20 off your first order
at thrivecosmetics.com toast20 that's
Thrive
c-a-u-s-e-medics.com toast 20 for 20 off
your order that's
t-o-a-s-t-2-0 thrivecosmetics.com
toast20 thank you Claudia you're welcome
our next story is a little romance news
that's gone the way of the horse and
buggy add them to the list Billy eilish
um
break up after less than a year as a rep
says they remain good friends no love
lost for me I didn't even know who this
person was he was a little bit weirdly
older than her like she had that like
weird cringy quote about him and that
was yeah she's like imagine like the
hottest [__] guy like
him not only knowing who I am but like
also being able to [__] pull him
that's what she said and honestly I'm
gonna be able to look at her the same
sense
I haven't been able to look at the
relationship the same since so now that
it's over I think we can like resume I'm
just like happy to move on like pretend
like this never happened honestly yeah
I hope she's okay like I never stand no
I don't know honestly he could come over
and kiss me in the mouth and I would say
so who are you like I don't even know
what he looks like yeah and I'm okay and
I never really wanted to know who he was
you know no this was information just
kind of like thrust upon me no because
it's also just your relationship to
Billy as well like if Taylor was dating
Jesse Rutherford all of a sudden we love
oh my god did you hear about this open
letter what swifties are unwell what
there's an open letter like somebody
wrote to Taylor signed all the swifties
like [__] don't include me in your
[__] letter okay they're all mad
about Maddie because he's problematic
they said he's anti-semitic so of course
my ears went up and I watched the
footage and honestly I didn't find it
offensive and I lowkey found it funny so
I don't know whatever yeah they're
labeling him with all the labels right I
saw a bunch of the um you know we're
excited and I think he's just like a
crazy provocateur I don't think he is
all of those things I don't think he's
anti-semiticism I don't think he's a
Nazi like Hitler like I don't think he's
a Nazi I don't think he's a Nazi like I
think if I'm just like kind of gonna say
something crazy like I think it was a
joke and honestly don't quote me on this
but like sometimes right time I plays a
Nazi salute joke is funny I'm sorry a
joke can be funny a joke can be funny
listen I actually did a Nazi salute joke
like with all my Jewish friends in
Nashville and like they thought it was
hilarious but like I can do it it killed
literally I didn't even mean it like
that no it literally like annihilated
it could be funny so I like don't think
he's a serious Nazi and so all the P
everyone was sending me like
anti-semitic seven it wasn't compelling
so then I just figured that I'm not
gonna go down the rabbit all the works
cited are not compelling yeah and I'm
sure you said stuff that like I maybe
wouldn't agree with or maybe I thought
the joke was too far that doesn't make
someone a bad person and so um it
doesn't mean like Taylor shouldn't date
them and the idea that the fans are
gonna tell them what to do with her her
personal life and the idea that the fans
know Maddie better than Taylor Taylor
who's spending every day with him for a
few months that they know something
about him that she doesn't know and that
she should act on is a real it's a level
of delusion it's a joke that's why like
I think like please don't don't write
open letters on behalf of other people
like you don't speak for me how many
people signed it so far I don't think it
was like a petition I think it was just
like a letter honestly I don't know but
like everyone was talking about on Tick
Tock I'm like these people have lost
their [__] minds these people have
lost their [__] minds but we've lost
the plot I feel like right it hasn't
gotten like loud enough for it to
actually affect Taylor as we've seen
when she doesn't even look at stuff
about herself it's still on my like
Niche Community like it's not big yet
also like Taylor dating like someone um
like controversial controversial I kind
of like that for her me too because
she's always a goody goody like doing
what everyone wants like no yeah take
the anti-semite queen love that for you
foreign
yeah yeah maybe next it'll be Jesse
Rutherford though yeah almost just gonna
make like an actual bad joke that like
wouldn't have been funny so I used my
judgment and we love that um but what
does he do
who Jesse rather not a club he does
something that inspires her though like
I think it's music inspires her remember
because that's what she said yeah yeah
how would she know who he was right
no like I the level of care is just not
there for me on this story yeah no I sat
here for 40 minutes picking stories
sorry I was late oh my God wrote it in
my face it wasn't about you oh wow wow
just like and I that was the last resort
like because it's all about Scandal yeah
and yeah at a certain point I needed to
just make a choice Shake It Up Chicago
it's all about choices life is always
good it led us to talk about that all
the Maddie drama yeah no and that was
funny like I'm I'm not mad you're not
Matty I'm not Maddie oh my God I forgot
to tell you remember earlier in the week
we were talking about the name Maddie
and I said you know my favorite show
Awkward yeah guess who jammed you're not
gonna know what it means but I'll
explain it Greer grammar she's not
awkward she was on Awkward the show was
talking about so Kelsey grammer's
daughter and she's a toaster she's like
I've been listening for years I was like
dying when you brought up awkward I'm
like you're I was wondering
malfunctioning you're a toaster wonder
what she thinks about Camille Grammer
maybe I'll ask her that if she's like
she's like a meal's daughter no no no no
okay that's actually look at me like I
gotta stop talking and like answering I
don't think so where she isn't you know
what I mean like well that is true
either so is
I feel like she might not be because I
don't remember Camille those kids were
so young no her mother is Barry Bruckner
okay actor uh a makeup artist
yeah so that's just like something
exciting that happened to me today
that's cool thanks for sharing well
Taylor won't listen to the toast
Greer grammar well and that's good
enough for me yeah are you ready for our
fifth and final story fine another
another story that I passed it a number
of times before I chose it okay Khloe
Kardashian is slamming the exhausting
rumors about her interest in Thompson's
relationship status this is newsworthy
I'll give you it yeah so Chloe wants
people to stop talking about her
relationship with X love Tristan Chloe
you and I want the same thing literally
she said stop pushing this narrative
it's tiring she added in response to a
fan page screenshot from dumwa that read
Kim supporting Tristan at the Lakers
game what is going on face emoji what is
this Emoji connote I don't know like I'm
melting I don't know like the wicked
witch every time a celebrity either like
directly calls out dumois or like
something like this do you think like
Dumont like dies inside
I feel like it happens a lot it does
happen a lot I feel like it's Case by
case how Dumas feels about it yeah I
feel like this one is did you want
didn't like say anything she just like
posted someone asking a question right
so I think I think Chloe's more so
responding to that fan than like do more
for person because you know a lot of
people had questions I think we sat here
and asked a question as well I think we
did can I ask you a question why was Kim
Kardashian sitting at the Lakers game
while North had a poster that said
Tristan Thompson simple questions yep
but Chloe has the answers stop pushing
this narrative it's tiring uh
had said posted allegedly he's back with
Coco so maybe she saw soft launching the
idea so everyone is prepared and doesn't
give Coco a hard time like stop calling
her Coco like that's what her nieces and
nephews because I wouldn't even call her
and I would never never liable about her
she said I suppose you guys will
continue the narrative if you want
regardless of what I say so what's the
point it's exhausting but I learned
people will only understand to the level
of their own perception most are stuck
at believing the lies because it's the
narrative they want to fuel have fun I
mean some things are just as simple as
they seem a family member supporting
another family member especially during
a difficult time in life example just
how I support Scott and will forever
support him he's my brother love that
it's not just an NBA stage sad new world
if there's no photos people think it
didn't really happen but yes I see Scott
often some things really are just as
they are no that's a decent example yeah
no the thing is it's like nothing
they're doing is abnormal for their
relationship with Tristan who's true's
father but it's also not abnormal what
they're doing if he she he he was in a
relationship with Chloe like you know
what I mean yeah like they're both like
everything they're doing is something
normal you do with your sister's
boyfriend and something normally you do
with your cousin's dad like
so it it is easy for people to jump to
conclusions yeah but she cleared it up
cool yeah she did clear it up she's been
clearing up like some stuff recently
she's really been feeling like Texas I
love the direct communication but I also
feel like
like I mean it's her phone she probably
sees everything about her all the time
and apparently she was like walking into
the hotel in New York and people were
chanting Courtney at her yeah and so she
posted that to her story as well
um and I just feel like she ends up like
giving a lot of energy to things that
don't require require it and like
shouldn't matter so much to her
considering like she needs to zoom out I
agree but I'm sure it's almost
impossible for her and it's literally
they're chanting it at her yeah but like
the fact that you're gonna say to your
like 60 million followers something that
like 20 people did
perhaps the video was going viral I
didn't see it I didn't see it either
it's like not the biggest deal in the
world no it's not and I'm sure like I I
really feel for her because the amount
of anxiety that she suffers from being
in the public eye right now like is more
than ever before and she was actually
the sister who was like had the best
tolerance for it to start so I think
she's really like suffering I just I
wish she could find a way to like see
her herself the way that most of us
normal [__] people I know if you ever
get a chance to meet her you should tell
her that I honestly feel like it would
like really move her honestly that was
beautiful
Claudia so we'll clip it maybe we'll
clip it and we could tag her yeah
because she sees her Instagram so true
she sees what people have to say maybe
do more could repost it for us so it
really kind of gets on across her desk
love you Chloe let's put that at the end
adorable
um okay well that's that that's that on
that I've been wearing a bodysuit since
7am yeah you have like I can't stop
moving you're gonna need surgery no
Jackie if I literally put my fingers
down my throat I could pull the body
suit out of my mouth if you pick your
wedgie one more time I'm starting to get
canceled I'm literally like this body
suit is up my [__] [__] like it's
insane so we don't want you to get a UTI
right so I gotta go she's gotta go
before her urinary tracts and infection
thank you guys so much for listening to
the testimony Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories dating to
whatever Monday through Friday on
YouTube so we're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to
subscribing give this video a thumbs up
we're also available because anywhere
podcast coming down so it's Spotify
agencies box all the places
standing in wickedly talented we are
hope you guys have an amazing day and
we'll see you tomorrow for a very
special edition of Friday's episode
because we will be doing deer toaster I
won't make fun of addition thank you
have a great day love you bye